[Music]
out of a story you'll see only on 10
after a day on the water takes a
terrifying turn for boaters and the
group was out fishing when they suddenly
geez it's really hot like it's annoying
me that's not only hot but like insanely
well put together right right yeah yeah
like you know it's one thing to be a hot
it's another thing to to Really dress
tonight you're like okay this is [ __ ]
yeah found themselves Under Fire local
attention live now on all over the beach
with our exclusive tonight Rush
did you sleep in your car everyone
listen to these details this fisherman
says he is fortunate to be alive okay
why are the why are the correspondents
out there always there they're always
[ __ ] up he's another one that looked
like he had the shirt in his car I'm
telling you this guy's [ __ ] up why he
actually told somebody here look you
cannot fish off sounds like he's running
a political race against [ __ ] Dr Oz
oh my God he's fettering the guy who saw
this one guy's got a boat and then
they're like they're circling at it you
know they're like you can't fish here
you son of a [ __ ] that ain't got real
personal you know it's like all right
stuff goes and now we have the boat cops
here and uh the whole thing
hey is Quarterdeck open
like
I don't want to be there
the doc here at Haulover a few moments
later he says this guy comes back and he
just starts firing starts blasting he
just starts blasting shot after shot
after shot in fact here's one of the
books oh my God
he's picking up one of the show bullets
in my hand right now am I why is your
hand shaking are you okay let me date
police they want to catch this guy yeah
that's your job you probably shouldn't
take in the shell casing off the crime
scene
do we want to catch the guy right I
found this in a in a clear plastic bag
in the trunk of a police car with a bag
that's in evidence I know I broke a red
seal and now it's in my hands it would
be even better if he didn't even break
this if you literally just contaminated
the crime scene he's like before office
was arrived I removed these bullets he
walks through DNA evidence he takes a
leak he takes a leak on on DNA evidence
starts trimming his nose hairs and [ __ ]
he's like look they called me because
because I see that houseboat over that's
where I live and then he finishes a beer
and he just breaks the bottle right in
the crime scene let's [ __ ] go
again
well we can't see him from the waist
down so maybe he's slurring because he
actually got shot during the altercation
he's like yeah I found this showcasing I
pulled it out of my leg pulled it out
with a pocket knife I found the cops
were asking me to talk but I take my job
really seriously I'm really tired I'm
really tired back to you Tom
that's a [ __ ] nice boat though [ __ ]
that's got the cabin when you think of a
marina you think of fishing fun cocaine
don't think of gunfire and people
ducking for cover well you know it
depends on what you're doing the
Gasparilla
you see it depends on which Marina yeah
every Town's got the shooty one mm-hmm
walking through the grass here he
ordered uh two of my friends to get back
onto the boat and he just started firing
rounds at us is this guy just to defeat
or those are the bullets he is still
frightening someone's hand where they
shouldn't be this is this has got to be
one of the botchiest news reports I've
ever seen hey can I just uh record audio
I just don't want you guys to show my
face because I don't want anybody to
catch me all right we'll just film your
dick what we could just blur me out you
can blur me I threw the robot voice
Maybe
he was just gonna film you dick hey I
wasn't I was on channel 10 well my dick
and feet were seriously it matched being
this camera guy and that's like so
you're just filming some guy's dick
that's what it was like could you
imagine walking past the news crew
and they're talking to some guy okay
he's pointing down what are you doing he
didn't want me to show his face so
you're filming his dick
why my dick and feet sounds like a
Butthole Surfers
or or a peck song yeah
he's put this fisherman is sure lucky to
be here and this is insane it's a crazy
world we live in nowadays bullet after
bullet tells this story it all happened
at holliber Marina Sunday
two bullets
is the worst it was it was a tour a
torrent of bullets a barrage
a volley a [ __ ] shootout
there's just body strewn everywhere the
fishing boat that caught bullets instead
of fish
I'm done with you you're fired he was
[ __ ] proud you're fired you're fired
and I'm gonna have security remove you
remove you from the building so he
orders you on the boat and then go back
to this guy's thinking feet It's Gonna
Keep Going why the story is so what is
up ABC then you couldn't like film a
boat while he talked boom boom what did
the gunshots sound like uh 40 cal going
off by the way boom boom and this guy
knows his guns you get this it was
actually a 40 cal going off how would
you come on buddy
certainly
oh look at that it sounded like a 40
caliber Smith and Wesson that I bought
the other day yeah right we
yeah I mean I literally handed you the
bullets why do you think I don't want
you to film fill my face yeah I don't
hear about a story like this every day
take a look at this it's Scotty
truly what is all the Slugs the bullets
pulled out you see what I mean even
imagine what was going through this
model and he doesn't get his first drink
this guy is going nuts over this
non-story this is a non-story and this
guy is acting like he's on the big this
is [ __ ] literally uh uh the The
Untouchables or whatever going after
[ __ ] Al Capone like that's what this
feels like he's like got this big
Crusades going on Jesus this is Jim
Garrison trying to figure out what
happened to [ __ ] JFK calm down dude
it all started he says simply because he
told someone no fishing here the next
thing you know he is under Fire I can
see you're still shaken up by this oh
yeah obviously I was just almost
murdered the other night
and now there's a cameraman just like
pointing a camera on my dick so that's
big so it's been a weird week it's been
[ __ ] weird okay that's pretty much it
oh that was a good one